bonsoir merci d'être avec nous doit-on
être surpris ce soir par le verdict de
ce procès n'avait lui non recevoir non
je pense qu'il n'y a strictement aucune
surprise quant au verdict cela fait très
longtemps que navalni tire sur la corde
pour dire les choses simplement et la
corde rompu la patience de la russie a
pris fin donc ça fait quand même des
années que la vanille est en liberté
conditionnelle ça fait des années qu'il
a se positionne comme étant au-dessus
des lois
la loi vient simplement de le rattraper
il faut comprendre que le fait de voir
sa peine de prison transformée en prison
ferme quand on a systématiquement violé
les conditions de sa conditionnelle
c'est quelque chose de tout à fait
normal donc simplement la vanille et
traiter ici comme n'importe quel citoyen
russe auraient été traitées sauf que un
bon citoyen russe aurait été de
souhaiter ainsi beaucoup plus tôt c'est
solide alors alexeï navalni ne pouvait
pas ignorer ce qui l'attendait en russie
il a décidé de revenir sur le sol russe
comment l'expliquer une stratégie de sa
part de vouloir revenir justement dans
son pays peut-être pour y être
victimiser où il faut chercher une autre
piste tout d'abord effectivement oui
c'est un scénario s'est monté ça se voit
il suffit de voir le nombre de
représentants diplomatiques aujourd'hui
au tribunal pour voir que derrière des
mises en scène absolument parfaite
mais rappelons quand même que navali n'a
pas aidé si pressé que ça de rentrer
dans son pays
et c'est justement ce qui pose problème
aujourd'hui puisque il a été quatre
semaines en prison il est resté quatre
mois en allemagne
fin octobre le service d'exécution des
peines russa a commencé à lui en
demandant où il se trouvait
d'après ses réponses au tribunal il
estimé que tout le monde était au
courant et qu'il avait autre chose à
faire que de répondre donc finalement en
fait il a commencé à réagir fin novembre
vaguement et il a fallu réellement qu'il
y ait une menace de poursuites
judiciaires pour qu'ils rentrent
finalement en russie donc on peut pas
dire qu'il soit rentrer tout de suite en
bon citoyen conscient de ses obligations
auprès du tout il est possible aussi que
ses sponsors commencent à trouver leurs
factures un petit peu lourde et que
maintenant il faillit rentabiliser ce
que l'on voit parfaitement avec les
manifestations organisées dès son retour
puisque chaque chacun savait très bien
que et anglais l'aviation us
ils allaient être interpellé l'arrivée
et c'était d'ailleurs le but et avec le
cirque la mise en scène qu'il a faite au
tribunal qui à la limite d'une à jour
système judiciaire parce que il était
l'utilisation d'une affaire
techniquement du ludique
alors on le sait avec ça une avanie a
des ambitions politiques quel avenir
pour cet opposant politique à vladimir
poutine
son avenir est pour l'instant
principalement dans la presse
occidentale et dans les chancelleries
occidentales
ils ont cas lorsque l'on regarde le
nombre de personnels âgés personne qui
peut mettre dans les rues il est évident
qu'il est beaucoup plus intéressant s'il
est vivant en prison ou ciment en étant
une victime sacrificielle puisque pour
l'instant ce mouvement a sérieusement
besoin donc tout l'intérêt de ses
sponsors c'est de le voir en prison
réellement dans la rue et en liberté il
ne représente quasiment rien parce que
finalement il n'a rien à proposer et il
n'est pas là pour proposer quoi que ce
soit il n'est pas une alternative n'est
pas une opposition constructive
il est là pour détruire un système et la
focalisation qu'il a dans ses discours
face à vladimir poutine montre à tel
point c'était la limite de la
mégalomanie
parce que lorsqu'il passe dans ce qu'il
déclare que les cils sont des millions
dans la rue
personne n'osera rien faire pour
l'instant il a déjà du mal à mettre
quelques milliers de personnes dans la
rue et dans toute la russie
donc nous le sent quand même assez loin
d'eux
un mouvement populaire de millions de
personnes qui mangent dans le crime
alors en tout cas l'europe occidentale
ne vois pas de la même manière jusqu'aux
états unis d'ailleurs il ya eu des
réactions très rapide
l issue de ce procès longs berlin paris
moscou tous demandent sa libération
immédiate à ce que l'endroit craindre
une détérioration encore plus grand des
relations entre l'europe occidentale le
monde occidental et la russie
effectivement il va y avoir et il y a
déjà six derniers temps une
détérioration grandissant des relations
entre la russie d'une part et la russie
est un pays occidental je dirais plutôt
et le mans globalis puisque nous sommes
face conflit idéologique d'une part un
monde unipolaire globaliste américaine
au centre et d'autre part une vision du
monde pluriel qui est proposée par la
russie sont des visions qui sont
actuellement compatible donc l'arrivée
de baida à la présidence aux états unis
ne fait que relancer encore plus soir ce
combat qui est portée aux états unis par
les démocrates principalement
donc oui effectivement d'autre part nous
voyons comme une faiblesse politique un
alignement idéologique des pays
européens et de l'union européenne en
tant qu'entité qui d'ailleurs existe
pour cela
donc effectivement la dégradation est à
est à suivre de certainement peut-être
de nouvelles sanctions sont encore à
attendre et la question d'un stream 1 2
revient à nouveau sur devant la scène et
on voit bien ici d'ailleurs à quel point
tout ce jeu sert principalement les
intérêts atlantis des américains et de
tous les intervenants
merci beaucoup karine bêcher colloque au
professeur mitaine l'université d'état
de moscou d'avoir été avec nous en
direct sur rt france